I mean,
the first barber I went to
was a white English guy
and I got butchered.
I was absolutely butchered
to the point where,
on Monday,
when I went
into primary school,
I didn't want to
take my cap off.
Of course not.
And, when I took it off,
the laughter was worse than
it is here.
-That's the worst, isn't it?
-It was horrible.
About as quiet as a mouse?
Download Tinder.
Download Hinge.
Trust me.
Your girl is out there, fam.
Gus, how long
have you been married, mate?
I've been married
for 39 years.
I'm still together
with my wife.
Raised by my grandmother.
She gave as much love
as she could give
and I have that
to be grateful for.
I went on Tinder
to chat to girls, alright?
And it just so happened that
I chatted to the girl
that became my girl.
I went to a party
in Thornton Heath
with a mate of mine.
I saw her and it was weird.
I just knew straight away
that
I would marry her.
I knew that straight away.
I started chatting with her
and she gave me
a bogus telephone number.
I was gutted.
I was totally
and utterly crestfallen.
But there was a party
at the same house
three months later.
I finessed things
a lot better than I did
the first time around
and we arranged to
meet again afterwards.
And we've been together
ever since.
I think, for me, the
most important part of that,
in all honesty,
was to be able to transfer
that onto our children.
We don't realise
how much we model
what we want
our relationship
based on either
our parents' relationships
or significant relationships
that are in our,
you know, in our family
or in our network.
We take a lot of that in
subconsciously.
For me, having been raised
predominantly
by my grandmother,
traditional,
typical, Jamaican…
Everything she did was
for the three of us.
To be a woman
in her mid-60s,
to take on
three grandchildren,
raising them
while your daughter
has absolved herself of
responsibility.
She is and always will be,
you know,
my role model, my hero.
Some people walk in
and then they go straight
into the chair!
I've been here
for an hour and a half.
My dad used to cut my hair
when I was a little boy.
But the funny thing is
my dad has been bald
for so many years
and,
when he used to cut my hair,
he forgot that he needed to
comb out the knots.
He'd have the razor
just going…
And I was just like: "Ah!"
He'd be like:
"I didn't know."
Growing up, my parents were
very affectionate.
You know, my mum was always
a very loving person.
She loved to
get people together.
She always wanted to see
other people happy.
She was always sort of
sacrificing
her own happiness
for
other people's happiness.
A lot of that
has rubbed off on me.
Especially after
she passed away,
I feel like I've kind of
embodied her in some way.
I sort of took on that role
in a way because
I wanted to feel like
mum was still…
That she's present,
spiritually
or in whatever way.
There's something
in our society
which has definitely been
rooted in my upbringing
which basically suggests
that, as men,
we should suck it up,
you know?
We should just deal with it
internally.
We don't need to be
cathartic.
We don't need to talk
and communicate.
And that really stymies us.
I guess,
also from my perspective,
just reflecting,
it just holds us back from
having the space to actually
not only receive love,
but also as well show love
and care
when people are going
through challenges,
when people put up
the flags.
Coming out
of a relationship,
I was with her
for 16 years in total.
And, since we split up,
I've been exploring,
trying or striving to be
more vulnerable with my
emotions and sharing more.
Because I really do see that
that was one of the reasons,
the big reasons,
why I've gone through
my divorce.
And maybe
I put too much of that on
her telling me how she felt,
but she probably couldn't
tell me how she truly felt
because I hadn't created
a safe environment
for her to do just that.
I don't know where the need
to be stoic is rooted
or where it's coming from,
but I know that it's passed
down from my dad.
You know, he's old school.
He's, you know, never
gonna talk to you about
what he's feeling.
But I remember,
at one stage,
he turned around and said:
"Carl, look."
"I think I'm depressed."
And I squirm at
my response to that
because,
when I look back at that,
my response was: "What do
you mean you're depressed?"
"Stop being silly. Come on.
Man up." You know?
And I see that almost as
a cry for help.
And, yet still,
my response was
one that he instilled in me
of being
just ridiculously closed.
Yeah, I just think that
if I was probably
a bit more open to
recognising the signs
and recognising
what he was going through,
then, yeah,
I could have been a bit more
supportive to him.
I've been
a very angry young man.
I was definitely going down
the wrong path.
I used to worry because
I had so many girlfriends
that I just didn't think
I was ever going to meet
someone
who I could live with
or who could tolerate me,
you know?
But then it happened.
You know, one or two people
have said about, you know,
creating space.
I created space to allow
someone to come in
and now be that person that
I wanted and looked for,
you know?
There's so much luck
in these situations.
I moved to London in 2000.
In 2001, I met Hazel
and my instinct just told me
that
there was
something about her
so, while I didn't know
where it was going to
end up,
you know,
I followed my instinct.
We got married in 2008.
Had our first son in 2009.
Baby number two, Mr. Isaac,
was due end of March 2013.
I took her to the hospital.
At seven o'clock
in the evening,
she gave birth to Isaac.
But by
two o'clock
the following morning,
so just about five hours
later, she died.
And I wasn't supposed to be
a single dad
with a three-year-old
and a newborn baby
having to tell
Aaron at three that
his mum had died
and she wasn't coming back.
He spoke about
what it was about Hazel…
Yeah.
I saw my grandmother in her.
That's it.
So I've lost the two women
the closest to me
in the world,
but I'm still here.
It's interesting, isn't it?
Because we do have
the barber shop,
but we don't talk about
those types of things.
We have the rum shop,
but we don't talk about
those types of things.
You know, we go to…
There's a betting shop,
but we don't talk about
those types of things.
But we do meet a lot,
you know, as black men.
We don't have
those discussions.
I don't think I had that,
you know.
You know
how we're kind of fed
this definition of
masculinity as well?
Yeah.
I wasn't that definition of
masculinity.
Barber shops,
I would say are
a safe space for most,
but definitely from my peers
that are in the LGBTQ+,
it can be challenging to
find a safe space.
Even myself, my confidence
in barber shops.
It was always a case of:
ok, go in,
get your hair cut, leave.
So…
It's generally a safe space,
but what about the people
on the fringes of it?
I think James Baldwin talks
about
something as
a state of abjection
and that's to feel as a
foreigner in your own home.
You know,
a lot of times we're taught
or the definition of
black masculinity
has been sold to us
as some sort of
hyper-masculine
kind of structure
or construct.
I fully get you on that.
When you talk about tribes,
it's actually
really important.
I'm lucky enough to have,
like,
a sick, sick group of mates.
We've got this group
called Feelings
and that's separate to
a number of other groups
that we're all in.
What we all try and do is
just support each other
and, whatever anybody's
going through,
we allow each other
that space
to be vulnerable,
to be your authentic self,
I feel.
We're not all trying to do
the male thing
and be like:
"I'm a big man, yeah!"
"I'm nice.
Don't worry about me."
I think that takes
great strength
to be able to do that
and to be able to find it
in your heart
to be comfortable
in doing that.
Men who say that, you know,
men shouldn't cry…
In a way,
I feel sorry for them
because sometimes I think:
"Well, what do you do, then,
when you're feeling like,
you know, crying?"
I'm not afraid to cry
with my friends.
I've seen the vast majority
of my friends cry,
especially my closest pals.
This is what being masculine
is about.
I don't care what
their friends are doing.
I'm not doing what
their friends are saying
or not saying.
I have to lead by example.
But not just for my boys.
In terms of
my responsibility, too.
In my community,
too many black boys,
too many,
too many black boys
going under.
There's a lot between these
ears, you know what I mean?
We just need the opportunity
to be able to speak about it
and really put ourselves
in positions that
we can have conversations
outside of things
that are just
physical prowess
or race relations topics.
There's so much more
out there
that we all wanna
talk about.
We get pigeonholed into
these boxes
and I think
a lot of black masculinity
falls into that at times.
For me and my experiences,
love really boils down to
respect.
It is acceptance,
completely,
of another person or people,
regardless of their flaws
and their greatness.
I think, for me, love is…
It's like a commitment,
duty.
It's responsibility that
you give
because
that is what you want.
The way I am right now
in my life,
it's really about the boys
and me and them
as a family unit
and there being love shared
between us,
us looking out for
each other,
us having each other's back.
-That's what it's all about.
-I hear that.